[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry Johnny oh hi I'm Justin from
experience 3 before you like my
we're just the camera
I'm not going to reliably I'd actually
known with the bridge on you mean what
if you got the oh that's a Robert
Redford oh my back no no I'm mr. Boulder
III agree surprised start over Oh
welcome to a movie who kept a penny
Yeah Yeah right
Oh what is wrong is nothing you do
rumors for the road backs video yeah
oh I love this follow up any stretch or
not Michael Wacha Mariano happen um one
of the okay oh okay there you go a
little not very
four four four six all right Stacey are
up okay all nervous number one I'm
rocking a chunky luck and just want
everyone to know that yeah all right
here we go
looks like a hurry that or that make and
the shoot any staff the book yeah yeah
oh
classification single do you reference
the videography night yeah yeah showing
movie permit okay this is all right well
I'll make them laying that you brought
rhetoric here almost down yeah Mel
Brooks okay this is a diam meeting and
go and Bette Midler and they are oh
please an invisible be okay don't for a
Bill Murray oh yeah very harder I've
never seen Caddyshack let everyone go
yeah yeah I you were nervous might have
to give the clues I'm friends going to
give an American clues and not a lot of
but there we go
oh okay holidays are basically the
corporate or always yes
oh my favorite romantic attraction
yeah oh let me be not look happy one
Jedi
well here three four five six seven
eight nine alright that was rhetorical